[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are off
the record officially
we're gonna whoa this guy's hardcore
it's called strength that was a demo
whoa that's strength cyber truck right
there dude oh [ __ ] i know you're strong
you made a cyber truck out of a bottle
i got a question for you guys yeah so
some of us
want to be here don't need to be here
and some of us need to be here
for
undisclosed reasons
for income purposes for income purposes
so far it's a very confusing statement
but
what is
your [ __ ] you jk cash out
price it doesn't exist unfortunately
because i like you guys i know right
well i know you you actually lose money
coming here dude because you have to pay
for tickets pay for a hotel and then by
the time you go back you [ __ ] break
even from the money we give you
so
what's [ __ ] you jk cash out price what
does that mean like 30 bucks that means
like 30 bucks what does it mean dude all
right you know everyone
there's an opportunity cost for anything
yeah even if you enjoy it right sure for
example like it could even be like oh i
got five kids now and as much as i want
to be here and talk to you guys like i
got other [ __ ] to do
right but then
also there's big timing that happens
like i want to do that it's like let's
say like that's the one i want let's say
like
tom cruise hits me up and goes joe man
i saw you on jk news
i'm a big fan of mission impossible
you're looking at my nine yeah i'm like
i wanna i wanna be i want you to be on
mission impossible and i'm like guys
this is an opportunity
i just cannot miss
i'm big timing you yeah we're doing jk
news on set at the initial impossible no
i'll find a way to bring you on though i
ain't gonna abandon it right that's too
bad because you tell them bart hey [ __ ]
you i'm in mission possible 9.
[ __ ]
am i kind of sick
and then i'll come crawling back after
the movies yeah yeah yeah yeah but yeah
guess who's in the movie uh tom hardy is
the cell phone bad guy so i'm about to
make it
here's another question though right
10 million dollars that's a lot of money
you don't really need to be here anymore
but
will you
i'm here
i'm here today luna's at the all-time
high 15 minutes ago i'm here yeah at 1
17.
we thought he was going to leave after
actually i'm not going to leave that
everyone thought i was going to leave
okay let's be real here okay let's cut
through the [ __ ] let's be real cut
to the [ __ ] the only even chance of
having [ __ ] money
all of us are already in the same game
it's most likely a crypto play and that
means that if i had this whatever
conceptual [ __ ] you money to be like i'm
a big time jk all jk has the [ __ ] you
money to big time me so it would be
different because then we would maybe
all be in a different financial does
that just mean it all resets and we're
just still in the same place yes we
would probably still just do jk people
knew because look when people love to go
like jk's going down it's like no we it
is going down
yeah sure the number is fine but you
know what i like i like to hang out with
you guys i don't care
and also we don't need this [ __ ] at all
i feel like i would record more videos
because then i have other projects and
businesses and things right but i mean
at 100 million dollars at that point
i don't know like maybe my projects will
just get bigger but i don't know if i'll
do
so many i think you would splurge like
for example like number one you might
finally patch up some of the holes in
the walls right over they'll never do it
that's what i'm saying number two
the samurai case that has nothing in it
maybe you don't need it
that's out of laziness because i didn't
put my samurai suit in from a value
proposition you don't necessarily need
it you know what i mean i'll have a hot
girl in a bikini samurai outfit in there
we might order better lunches but
michael's been doing a good job so he's
probably not going to kill him the
alcohol probably should be better that's
still nothing i mean i guess the
difference is like you know i'm starting
a business out in other places and i'm
gonna be gone and flying back and forth
and bart still you know has multiple
businesses or like everyone has other
things that they're doing right but
there's gonna be things that you might
scale back on
is what i'm saying if i had like 10
million dollars
it would be so i think
it depends on how you align with what
you want out of life
i think out of life the important things
to me what i've always been trying to
work towards is
free time
family that's close by and then
complete uh artistic like freedom of
artistic expression the three f's three
f's
so if freedom yeah and freedom of
artistic expressions okay so thank you
if if we all had let's say through the
crypto player right we all have [ __ ]
10 or 50 million dollars or whatever
then i would say [ __ ] everything and
let's just make the dumbest most
expensive videos ever
like the wolverine parody yeah like the
wolverine parody just make part two of
everything you ever kind of do already
some say we do that already but like
[ __ ] like we do our own
police chases and while they're filming
us we're filming them filming us that's
all you know what i mean like live on jk
news ktla filming jk news filming ktla
we we're like nightcrawler we make
exactly what we would do with the money
that's what i would do i think so so
we'll stay
we'll just do crazier [ __ ] if i have
[ __ ] [ __ ] one i'll stay here for
sure i'll quit changes
like because he has [ __ ] his money
like that's what the real price is
what's the number of that
50 bucks you care about free time if you
you said free time family okay rub it in
i don't have a kid yet i'm not married
yet i get it okay rub it in what i would
have zero project i don't care about
projects i think
i would build jk news studios in many of
the places i like to be like hawaii and
vegas and brothels
maybe maybe amsterdam whatever right
house brothels um la would just be for
if we want to bring on guests that are
[ __ ] hollywood nah dude [ __ ] yes dude
well big time them no more guests ever
i like them sometimes okay do all the
guests ever so you like pro like let's
say you had [ __ ] money right hundred
million dollars you would still have
projects that you do i think they would
just be in a different scale
and i will hire better people than me to
run it like magic [ __ ] johnson like
he has so many businesses
and he probably just kind of oversees it
and he makes executive decisions didn't
he also sell his share of the lakers
recently he did i don't know i think so
nobody's better but i'm pretty sure he
ain't there hiring and firing people
training people to work at his church's
chickens and like 24-hour fitnesses and
whatever right or does he own popeyes i
don't know he'll just shack isn't that
shaq was that a magic johnson's cagi
fridays and i was like
you know magic just does it all better
[Laughter]
the magic super sports the 24 hour
fitness those are pretty but yeah i
think i am passionate about building
businesses and things like that it's not
just about the money it's like the whole
lifestyle behind it or whatever but i
think what i want to do is create like
satellite studios everywhere and then
just be like dude it's like a retreat
every [ __ ] you know month or whatever
let's just shoot in hawaii and then like
everyone has the money to do it just
bring your whole family
since you guys are the like ultimate
like warlords of like jk and just ask
yes
if we really
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you money it's gonna be
sick when it happens not if when happens
right
do you feel like you're gonna change the
structure of jk if we're all like no
we're gonna stay regardless would you
change any of the structure it's like
will we be constantly shooting would we
be shooting on a yacht from now on yeah
like the sets will be different i think
that's what's probably going to happen
is the money will just flow back into
the company because now we don't really
need it needed like so it's like let's
just make the best videos ever without
worrying about youtube demonetizing us
yeah but remember when you guys got like
all that funny you open this big ass
office you made jk new sick as [ __ ] and
all the fans were like no no go back to
your shop but that's but that's because
we're still dependent right like if we
had [ __ ] [ __ ] money i would rape
people's eyes i made one video a year so
small one real year a crazy ass movie
it's like a feature film but it's a jk
news but then i project it on the
[ __ ] i don't know statue of liberty
and people have to watch it statue of
liberty a [ __ ] a boeing 747 with the
projector [ __ ] projecting it onto the
ocean that's why we we're gonna follow
you to the end of time you know what's
next level we shot it with a statue of
liberty shaped camera
you [ __ ] idiots oh yeah you guys
thought bart was an idiot no you're an
idiot you know what i would do perfectly
lines up with the statue of liberty a
[ __ ] idiot
100 lined up with a stupid torch too yep
i would
[ __ ] torch why does it need to be
there we already get it
you guys know those uh flip books right
where it tells a story like like an
animated film yeah yeah i know so i
would buy
[ __ ] um
i would buy those advertisements on the
road all the way all the [ __ ] way
across the country and the only way to
watch this jk news is to drive by and
watch every single frame of the ship
passing through live that's tight that's
[ __ ] tight i like that next level so
inexpensive too yeah flipbooks are cheap
right and then we're back to the studio
after that one episode dude that's type
dude i like that just like trump tower
trump tower we buy it yeah guess what
it's the new jk we're changing it up now
we're back online
ran out of money
that's the most you could do we make one
sick-ass statue of liberty film
afterwards we're out of [ __ ] money
what it was for [ __ ] us money now before
we start a new [ __ ] series where we
try to sniff out all those [ __ ] that
jeffrey epstein is trying to hook up
i'll go undercover as a [ __ ]
eight-year-old and try to seduce these
that's good yeah
and then we turn them all in
are you are you holding a chicken saute
spear right now hey hold the water gun
instead water gun that's how you look oh
he's young i like bubba gum what the
[ __ ] today's video is brought to you by
tushy you know what's interesting is
that i always said to myself
if i fell in the park and there was dog
[ __ ] right yeah and it smeared all over
my arm i'm not gonna get a dry paper
towel and [ __ ] rub it and throw it
away right call it clean yeah it's still
cocka just smeared all over it's not
gonna smell good but why did we do that
to our buttholes that don't make no
sense yeah okay you get toilet paper and
you just smear cocka all over those butt
cheeks and you just leave it there
that's pretty nasty and people wonder
why their underwear smells like cocka
and that's why there's a skid mark
epidemic but tushy here wants to help
all of us out they sent me a nice little
bidet kit that i had for several years
now and because of them i don't smear
kaka all over my body anymore my
favorite thing about them is that you
don't need an electrician you don't need
a plumber it's so easy to use you could
do it yourself because some of the other
ones you've got to have a
outlet built into your bathroom or
you're going to drag some super ugly
cord that goes into it and it's really
hard to put together this one it's so
easy just connects to it and it sprays
your butthole nice and clean and all you
gotta do is pat dry and now your
butthole and your underwear smells good
the whole day basically installed in
less than eight minutes for me yeah it
was pretty easy so we want you guys to
have clean butts just like us go to
hellotushy.com
off to record to get 10 off plus free
shipping that's hello to she.com off to
record to get 10 off plus free shipping
dude that's dope we should do that and
then we [ __ ] expose these
you're gonna go down the list expose
them oh yeah we flip and instead of
doing jk we do kind of like a ketchup
predator thing is that what you mean
flip it called kj and then we put we put
these guys in the hot seat where we ask
them the real questions yeah yeah yeah
kids jailers
so you call them yeah kj kid jailers
or when you guys when you guys all make
your [ __ ] you money
steve green you bring steve green's
production back and you make him just do
man on the street [ __ ] but like steve on
the streets craziest level yeah i maybe
would do it but i probably am too rich
to do it we'll see
back then it's like oh my even my camera
guy's like dude are you gonna [ __ ]
get your ass kicked today on my i don't
know just filming if it happens we'll
see just uh do your normal crypto corner
just call it luna gaines gun sexual
movies was good what and i think it went
sexual recently though
today i mean all you gotta do is hire
black rock or black water to [ __ ]
protect you we got bart here that's what
what bart
bart i'm undercover as an eight-year-old
all i know is that me and joe suck at
crypto because we're buying luna at five
dollars and like killers it only went to
117.
you guys got [ __ ] you money so there's a
budget to pay for a guest which guests
will be buying oh that's a good one
that's a good one i mean
we have the [ __ ] money right [ __ ]
money i wouldn't even think in that way
i would [ __ ] like let's like if i
have [ __ ] money like let's say i want
to elon right instead of bringing that
stupid [ __ ] here i find out what
building he's at i fly a helicopter to
the [ __ ] 50th floor did you sell the
helicopter no i throw him a styrofoam
cup with the string and i'm in the
helicopter with the styrofoam cup and
then we do jakey news like that yeah
yeah really loud it's very loud
but
i can't really i guess that neutralizes
all the sound though yeah helicopter he
turns it off obviously okay my bad
you got to do [ __ ] the other way if you
have that kind of money can i pay
jessica simpson to get hot again
um you said she's not hot anymore well
she's a billionaire enough she doesn't
give a [ __ ] yeah she is is that crazy
she's a billionaire she says she liked
playing the dumb ass on the show but
she's actually really smart and she
clearly is she's a billionaire she's
undeniable that's like what i try to be
but like i can't she's still with the
nicolas shea what the [ __ ]
dude that's the last time i heard her
name she she's with that [ __ ] chick
that looks like filipino but not oh
she's with a chick i think so listen but
but here's the best thing here's the
best thing how many clothes did you hear
well it's like i've seen all three
spiderman
how many quotes have you heard jessica
simpson's so stupid she's not chicken of
the seed
right she's undeniable she's a
billionaire she's undeniable what are
you gonna do oh she got lucky steve
that's just how did she make her money
she bought luna uh well clothing oh yeah
christina aguilera and no billy there
yeah
shots fired at christine aguilera
sometimes you're just undeniable you
don't have to prove anything to anybody
anymore yeah
like sometimes
who else he's a [ __ ] fergie fergie
[ __ ] avril lavigne avril lavigne i
heard avro's like really doing well
with um water bottles really really
[Laughter]
she's got an insurance agency really nah
i just made that one up too
i can't wait to hear what joe wants to
do financially he's like nah i made that
[ __ ] up it's it's it's going to zero i
actually have a uh i mean they'll
probably steal it but i actually have
another like show idea
uh that i think would be dope it would
be called um
either the one the number two
or the person you never heard of and we
only bring in guests of siblings of
people that you know ron james's sister
lebron james brother
one degree away the other person yeah
and all the most famous people you could
think of live in the shadows obama's
obama's brother talk [ __ ] about your
brother dude he already does yeah yeah
does it obama's brother [ __ ] hates
obama
yeah he is like a super republican
brother who like loves trump and [ __ ] no
way you guys don't know about him no i'm
actually serious what's his name i can't
remember but he's an obama but no but he
iraq barack obama's brother
sucks
in afghanistan and i think it's mostly
rude in the fact that like um obama
wouldn't really help him there that much
so like he's like hey [ __ ] my brother
and then yeah he's actually made a lot
of money off of it yeah i would do a
show where it's about the the actual
famous person everyone wants to hear
about but it's their brother and sister
and then have them just talk [ __ ] about
you i think that's what would happen if
we have more like [ __ ] you money it's
just well
we actually have money now to do a new
show if we want to get out of crypto
we're killing again that's who we're
we're undeniable that's unfortunate i
have a lot of other things we picked the
asset that [ __ ] beat everything else
and so we're undeniable but then also we
are we're too scared to pull out
that's what she said
it's trying
so funny we're over here looking up
sangha leading oh sorry [ __ ]
yeah she's pretty hot do you think is
that was it what does she look like now
we're looking at we're looking at her
[ __ ] 97 people sharing with each
other can you find her find her linkedin
like what does she look like now
she's the next guest oh [ __ ] that'd be
crazy she if she was a guest here i'd
probably be sweating and quiet the whole
video you don't think i didn't know what
to say man we had some interesting
guests here
i'm just surprised you know like one day
mia khalifa was here yeah mia colleevo
was here she's so cool she's really nice
so nice who was the most like who who
was the guest that was like the biggest
surprise of like yo that dude was or
that chick or that dude was jacked off
the most too
yeah probably mia khalifa yeah yeah well
yeah i told ryan jack off to her he did
say that but none of us believed you
especially me and khalifa
it's true though i believe you but she
didn't believe you because you know how
i'm shameless about that [ __ ] but i had
a letter no like dude just so you know
you didn't have any power over me
actually i didn't jerk it to you too
good for her see if something came here
i would tell her i jacked off to her
well i think we all did would you tell
her yeah okay i will wait 10 minutes as
a guy with massive gain you guys got to
neg these tricks dude
my childhood friend
let me tell you something you tell these
[ __ ] they ain't nothing nothing son
you're sucking your [ __ ] dick by five
o'clock
and it's five for god 503 let's go let's
go
verbalization take your three minutes
they all didn't need to suck at your
dick who cares i wonder how successful
these guys actually are like the ones
that think like that i i bet it's like
barrel i really want to know like all
the advice and all that i mean it
depends what you mean by success because
they definitely have they definitely
have in-cell followers that's true go up
the chicks in public and like we paid
them they're my actresses hey you want
to make out yeah sure
and then like they start making out
and all these kids watching this [ __ ] at
home is just like
making out with chicks is so easy wow
you want to make out yeah
[Laughter]
it's pretty inspirational it's like you
gotta admit that's like kind of a
powerful like culture move it's
beautiful you know what i mean how many
times does that work out of ten never
zero zero zero right or do you think
that like girls are watching those
videos and they're thinking themselves
not like
not like oh my god these guys are gonna
do this more like girls like oh i'm
supposed to make out with anybody who
asked me oh that's good conditioning
it's called grooming that's a bad effect
we at jk support grooming 100
if joe's shaking his head we're [ __ ]
like no
what happened shameless like so this is
[ __ ] us money for sure
oh [ __ ] us money's good it's good to
know that there's no amount of money
that'll
get you guys to run away from here
okay well maybe 200 million but i gave
out 100 million you guys could say yeah
i'll [ __ ] run out of here at 200
million i would wonder why we're still
[ __ ] filming in this office if we're
still in this office then i'm like what
the [ __ ] guys
i'm like are you guys embezzling funds
nonstop
crazy [ __ ] if we had if we had [ __ ]
bad kind of money we need to go [ __ ]
go buy a glacier and then [ __ ] try to
melt it in the grand canyon we need to
buy it fill it up we should buy a
glacier do we need to buy one we buy
glaze are they free by the way i think
they're free but that's what i heard
maybe i'm wrong i'm not a financial
advisor it's a transportation you gotta
buy a plane right
see honestly that's what we do that's
what we do when we when you get some
[ __ ] you money yeah you just you just
try to play around with different drug
smuggling ideas yeah the idea of us
actually buying a plane because
i think we test the theory in real life
we see how well it works out and we make
a documentary dude that would be pretty
tight yeah we buy a plane we send an
email mass email out to all the kingpins
we know and we're like hey we have a
plane
oh let's do business let's go boys you
want to collab on this one we buy a
plane steven lynn buys a real shitty
plane
and then we see which one was better
which one will stay in the air longer
i'm thinking about shielding yeah i did
too he's gonna make it disappear
don't underestimate my cheapness all
right we got a couple million i don't
underestimate your cheapness i still get
free breakfast at hotels i don't
understand estimate your treatments
because i get i get a w-2 from here
[Music]
[Music]
you